this Marketplace of alternative
education sprouted from demand the
problem for the alternative education
scene is the expectations that people
set and the track record that they lie
about people spend two hundred thousand
dollars in four years and going to debt
that they can't get out of because
College promises nothing on the other
hand a guy sells a thousand dollar
course and promises that you're going to
make ten thousand dollars within 30 days
the course may be exceptional it may
teach a lot of skills but if someone
doesn't make ten thousand dollars in 30
days they hate the guy the game is
shifted also because YouTube has just
blown up a lot of really good stuff is
available online for free